welcome back to new rock stars it's me
Tommy B and I'm here to talk about my
main man or mental or mechanized
organism Modoc that's right we finally
got a good glimpse of Modoc on Monday's
new trailer for quantumania he looks
badass but if you're like me you might
not know a lot about Modoc other than
that he's a charter member of the big
head gang shout out Mt so let's get into
it all right we just saw the trailer we
got two quick glimpses of Modoc one
where he's marching with Ant-Man Cassie
Kang and a group of quantum Soldier and
one quick glimpse of him in his badass
battle armor we have a theory about the
MCU Monarch we'll get into later but
first let's go back and talk about
modoc's past iteration so we also know
Modoc was in the short-lived animated
comedy on Hulu and that version Patton
Oswald voiced a disgraced version of
Modoc trying to save his job and his
marriage watch it it's great it's
relatable it's a lot of fun Gone Too
Soon now in the comics 616 Modoc starts
off as George Tarleton who was a lowly
American technician working for aim
Advanced idea mechanics he joined the
team to help develop the Cosmic Cube but
was into a human computer by the
scientist Supreme they grew his brain to
give him superhuman intellect but with a
side effect of a massive Cranium which
was too much for his frail body and many
needed to be placed inside a life
support unit that was dubbed a doomsday
chair more on that later the process
also gave him a plethora of psychic
powers along with an ego and ambition to
match he went on to use his Newfound
powers to take control of the
organization that had experiment to them
now if aim sounds familiar it's because
we've already seen aim in the MCU it's
the organization run by Aldrich Killian
in Iron Man 3. it stands to reason that
aim will be making a comeback into the
MCU very soon so what does Modoc stand
for well that would be mental or
mechanical organism designed only for
killing
for killing now it was originally
supposed to be mental organism designed
only for computing but like all software
updates this one turned evil that's
right a little buggy a little thuggy a
little plug pluggy with the mental bolts
now in his early comic book life Modoc
is still a loyal aim employee which puts
him in direct conflict with Captain
America after aim kidnapped Sharon
Carter Modoc and cap battle it out on a
name submarine before Modoc tries to
kill everyone but ends up only killing
himself or so it seems the Red Skull
actually saves him with the Cosmic Cube
and Modoc is often running as his own
damn thing just like David pess pumpkin
Moda spends a lot of time in the comics
fighting Heavy Hitters like no more Dr
Doom and Hulk often these fights ended
modoc's assume death only to be
resurrected by that convenient Cosmic
Cube now let's get into modoc's ability
he's got super genius intelligence Modoc
possessed one of the most Brilliant
Minds on the planet he was created by
aim sacrificing his body for one of the
world's largest brains but with great
brains comes a tiny little frame so he
possesses enhanced intuition pattern
solving information storage and
retrieval and logical and philosophical
structuring so basically he's like that
boyfriend or girlfriend that was able to
outlogic you in any argument even if you
were right a gaslighter the ultimate
gaslighter if you will if you haven't
figured out that I'm a nerd by this
point in the video then I don't know
what to tell you I like to think I wear
my nerd cred on my sleeve and sometimes
I carry my nerd cred in my hands and I
make cool sounds with it when I do
jealous
An Elegant weapon this is the night
Reaper from owner saber an absolutely
badass lightsaber that looks feels and
sounds so realistic you feel like you
could bust it open and pluck the kyber
crystal right out of there don't do that
at home kids I'm just saying this thing
rules you can customize it to be any
kind of Jedi Sith or weird midpoint
between the two maybe a gray Jedi like
we heard in the old books the night
Reaper has an SN pixel soundboard with
16 sets of sound fonts whether or not
you want to sound like Luke Obi-Wan
Anakin or even Vader you can also choose
from nine blade colors nine sets of
Blade effects and nine different blade
ignition sounds but come on baby
I think we all know that's the best one
it's also got smooth swing technology
when you're swinging around I'm gonna
wave
it sounds as realistic as if you were
battling back Blaster bolts on the Death
Star say that three times fast if you've
got two Sabers you can take advantage of
the dueling features like flash on Clash
Blaster block lock up Loop and so much
more check out Ona saber on Instagram
and Tick Tock if you want to enter their
monthly giveaways or go to onasaber.com
and use code rockstars to save 20 at
checkout to get a saber of your own
blasters those are for brutes give me
this elegant ancient weapon any day
modoc's ability to predict probable
outcomes of tactical and strategic
scenarios was so Advanced that it
boarded on Clairvoyant his intuition was
heightened to the degree his hunches
were almost always correct Modoc had a
perfect memory with the ability to
recall every moment his vast intellect
made him one of the few beings who can
comprehend and build a Cosmic Cube now
what else does he have psionic powers
telekinetic Force Blast Forest Fields
telepathy and mind control now those are
all pretty powerful but perhaps the most
powerful thing he has is the Doomsday
chair now due to modoc's mutated size he
is no longer capable of unassisted
physical movement modoc's body is housed
within a technologically advanced device
which he refers to as his doomsday chair
that's what I call my toilet but I guess
Modoc uses his chair the Doomsday chair
in addition to providing structural
support for modoc's frame also magnifies
his psionic capabilities to the nth
degree though primarily a
self-sufficient device the Doomsday
chair can also be connected to a special
energy cradle that provides it with an
endless supply of power it's basically a
Tesla that works thank you Elon
empowering both the chair and the Cradle
requires massive amounts of energy
charging it up once can black out the
entire city of Los Angeles which
happened in the comments now let's talk
about his body Modoc has a humanoid body
he has a giant size metallic chair but
he's got a tiny little body because his
head grew so big that the rest of his
body kind of compensated by shrinking
down we're going to get to a reason why
that may be happening in this movie in a
little bit so while he has his doomsday
chair modoc's tiny body is made super
powerful even strong enough that he once
grabbed and snatched Iron Man out of the
sky with it so even though he has those
little arms they're still super strong
so let's talk about this new Modoc like
I said earlier this new trailer we got
on Monday showed Modoc in his battle
armor but it also showed him oh my God
is that Darren cross from Ant-Man one
now we know at the end of Ant-Man one
his arms shrank up maybe tiny little
dinosaur arms before kind of collapsing
in upon himself and he presumably
shrinks into the quantum realm
presumably to his death but did someone
interrupt that death did King rescue him
and made him Modoc because it looks like
Corey stole is back Darren cross is back
in this movie and it stands to reason
that he might get out of the quantum
realm and perhaps link back up with aim
and maybe we get uh the return of
Aldrich Killian you know or maybe we get
some aim scientists back it definitely
we're missing a big bad agency to fill
the void so I I do think we could see
aim back we're definitely getting Modoc
in this movie thanks for watching I'm
Tommy Bechtel don't forget to like this
video subscribe to new rockstars on
YouTube and be sure to pre-subscribe to
new Rockstar's new channel the Deep guys
launching February 17th the same day
that quantumania comes out follow that
channel handle on all socials at Deep
dive Dash NR follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at Tommy bech told follow new
Rockstar subscribe to new rockstars for
breakdowns and theories of everything
you love thanks for watching bye
[Music]
[Music]